[Music]
hello everybody
i'm josh walsh president of film
independent uh
sitting at home in my oversized cardigan
and uh
thank you all for joining us today for
this special conversation
uh part of our film independent presents
program um
around the amazing film nomad land um
before we get started a couple quick
thank yous are in order uh from film
independent first off thank you to the
hollywood
foreign press association our lead
funder for our year-round screening
program thank you so much
thank you to our screening partner
vision media who makes
everything we do possible and last but
certainly not least
thank you to the los angeles times ably
represented here today
by uh mark olsen um before i turn it
over to mark i just want to um i also
want to thank
fox searchlight i want to thank you for
everything you do for
distributing this amazing film and you
know as we go through this pandemic i
more and more
recognize different parts of the
industry that i think about in a new way
and distributors who are putting out
great work
i value them more than i ever have and
just looking at the legacy of
searchlight
the great films that they've supported
over the years we need this to continue
uh searchlight is an amazing company and
i couldn't be happier that they are
bringing nomad land to the world um i
also just want to mention
um molly and chloe are filmmakers that
we've supported film independent for a
long time and
so so happy for both of you and the
entire
nomad land team here today um congrats
on this film
everyone's talking about it is you know
it's on the it's on so and says list for
best films of the year
that's all great but this film
transcends year-end best of lists
by a mile and a half by so much this is
a film that people are going to be
talking about and watching for years
it's such a
stunning remarkable original film um
i could go on in in chris farley mode
gushing over the film and the filmmakers
but i think i should stop and turn it
over to
a brilliant critic and writer the one
and only mark olsen
mark take it away thank you josh and
it's really my pleasure to be here today
to
to lead this conversation on nomad land
which is already
one of the most acclaimed films of the
year it's winner of the golden lion
at the venice film festival the people's
choice award the toronto international
film festival
and the golden frog at the camera image
festival
and so we're joined today by producer
peter spears producer dan janvi
producer molly asher and producer
director
writer and editor khloe zhao thanks to
all of you for
for being here today and i i think the
film has just a really deceptive
simplicity to it and so i want to start
by asking uh
the robert the rubber [ __ ] rodeo
sorry the rubber [ __ ] rendezvous that
takes place in the film
it's a real event but you all sort of
staged it
for the purposes of the film chloe can
you talk a little bit about that
why something like that was something
you had to sort of put on
for the purposes of the film well i'm
going to throw that to molly asher
because that lady over there made it
happen
so you go ahead molly
um well i mean it's it's it's it's like
a
such an important event for for the
nomads and
um and so yeah we we talked about
actually maybe
putting it on during the real rtr but
then realized that we needed to have
more control over it ourselves so we
actually staged it to be
a little bit right before the real rtr
and
um yeah it took there were about 50
vans there were you know homes um and uh
it took a few months to put together um
and then
and then the the joy of seeing it all
all um
coordinated and set up was
truly remarkable i wish we had a video
of the behind the scenes of that
particular day
you'll see how how not glamorous
filmmaking is
when you see that
but it was a real trip too because like
we staged an rtr
and then the people who are in our rtr
ended up just having their own little
nomad land rtr
experience right right they all stayed
there
how reality and fiction are intersecting
and that rtr is kind of
like a little bit hard to and we
recreated an rtr
from like the early years which was a
smaller event and as we are finishing it
dovetails into the real rtr that was
happening which now
has grown from like uh you know what 50
people originally to
you know three thousand people ten
thousand i think ten thousand this year
the last year
yeah because as you're shooting
the movie and i understand it was kind
of an extended shoot like over many
months
is it sort of a traveling production
like i when i'm watching the movie i
kept thinking about when you're in a
location
you're probably not going back there so
like
chloe what's it like having the
production kind of on the move like that
i'm just being kept in this very
protective bubble by my amazing
producing team
you know i wake up in the morning i say
these are the new pages
and then make it happen and then i go
eat my food and then i go to set
and just everything sometimes we got
there the night before sometimes we got
in the morning off
but magically you know i got there
things are ready for me and these are
some of the cats they found locally for
me to pick from
um so i think i probably seen the the
least dramatic
and interesting version of that because
i think kept very safe
but i'm sure the others have seen the
last
fun part of that like you know having to
to to be on the move the whole time it's
like a caravan isn't it it's just
yeah and we shoot along the way from
from one
one location to the next like there
wasn't a moment that was lost but we
didn't
try and get get stuff one of my favorite
memories of you chloe was
directing the shots that we would get
between
locations like truly not a moment lost a
filmmaker
peter can you talk a little bit just
about the logistics of that of having a
production
on the move in this way i imagine it's
much different from a
more conventional shoot yeah i i mean i
can talk a little bit about my
experience with it
it was very different from how i've you
know
made a movie before uh it wasn't so very
different from the way molly made a
movie because molly and chloe's would
work together uh on
together and dan comes also from a very
production past and uh but some of that
being with ben zeitling and working with
real people so their
their addition to the team really uh
created for us the the safety net of
knowing that we it could be done
but even even more i think helpful or
equally helpful
was this um early sort of
boot camp that we did in august
september
where we actually shot for two months
because we needed some summer scenes
but we also i think chloe really
understood that we were all going to
have to figure out
how how we were going to move as this
caravan and this family
and how would we all trust each other
and how
paul this would happen when we were
shooting in the winter months and we had
half the amount of time each day and
we're freezing and we're sleeping in
you know horrible conditions and stuff
you know it was so good to have had this
kind of
boot camp experience that she really
built into and we all built into the
schedule
but once we had that and had that muscle
memory when we picked back up a few
months later
and were shooting again we fell right
into
this rhythm which also allowed us i
think the success of
chloe handing us new pages every morning
and even though it was
it was new things that we had to shoot
we it was within the framework of
of this uh skeleton that had been
created for months
um and with the help of you know just 30
what was our crew size 34
23 or 24 so being small also helped us
to
really pivot and to be very stealth in
our abilities to kind of get in and out
of where we needed to go or to change
direction if the story required it
uh on a given morning because molly is
this similar to the other
films you've made with chloe like is
this the process that the two of you
have kind of developed for how to make
movies
well this is the first one where it's
been traveling but it is similar in the
sense of the small
nimble crew and working with with
non-professional actors and
and being able to be flexible both with
what
chloe is discovering with with um with
her actors
and also what the the place and the land
is kind of giving us so
in that way it is very similar because
chloe can you talk a little bit about
writing to
like do you are you looking for
something you have to find it or you're
like
in a place and you write to it i'm
wondering specifically there's that huge
truck stop where
david straight theron's character starts
working as a as a grill cook and that
just looks like a
a really wild place to be this just
labyrinth
a lavender place and so do you find that
place and think oh
we have to shoot here or are you looking
for something that you need that's like
that
it's crazy to my parents back home that
i know more about
wardrobe south dakota than i do of
anywhere in beijing
i've known wardrobe south dakota for
about four or five years before
i decided to write it into the film
because that's the
that's the spot um um you know we shot
two films
in south dakota in that area i've been
to war drugs many times always wanted to
put it on film
and this is just seemed to be the
perfect and they have seasonal working
program
when molly came back saying oh yeah they
do have that i'll go oh let's write that
into
to the script but for me you know with
the with the team with the producing
team
early on say how do we set parameters so
we could uh
be free the parameters are the locations
it's the maps
and so so even though everything else
could be changed
but these are the location we we're
going to
and we're shooting at this time of the
year so that was actually the starting
point and then once we decide those i
write within those locations
because dan what are your experiences
like in having a production like this
on the move like what what are the
advantages of it and are there any
headaches that it creates um i
don't know it's my first time doing it i
will say that i'm fascinated by the
question of like
it being different i i don't i don't
think it's that different from
i i mean this in a good way i find it to
be actually quite an intuitive and
conventional process
and i think that comes from chloe and
chloe and josh
and there's a very clear way to make the
movie
and it requires being prepared in
advance to then be
open to whatever is happening so chloe i
think you just said it perfectly it's
like
there really is a screenplay that you're
prepping
the way you would prep a fiction film
like the same breakdowns the same
preparation
and then the only thing that changes is
just kind of a certain
mentality of how you approach your day
so
and that comes from how chloe and chloe
and josh are shooting the scenes
and having an openness to adjust the
story to
what's in front of them um and no i
don't i i thought it was incredible it's
like
you'd think it's impossible to go on the
road and do this but it's like
you're not you're you're not i kind of
think it's simpler than people think
it's like
you're on an away job so it doesn't
matter if you're staying
in wall drug or or scott's bluff
nebraska
i don't really think so if you just plan
ahead about travel days
so it's not a glamorous answer but
i do think in a nuts and bolts way it's
not as different as you'd think
we like to we'd like to create our own
myth but
you're getting the truth here yeah
really not like that
that different and also yeah i i i
think it's um it's interesting because
we we we usually get like
oh so did that just happen like the
trick
is for the further producing team and
from you know uh the creative team
is to make it feel like that you
actually think we're lucky enough just
show up and got it
but most months of the planning has to
be done ahead of time so me
and josh and friends and and the actors
we can be as free as we want to
because every time we make a decision
that is not planned
they've planned every possible scenario
that they will have it ready to supply
what we want
we got lucky though a few times what you
you turned to me a few times and said i
always have weather luck
the weather is something yes and you
know what but at the same time
weather is like uh i remember the day we
were gonna shoot something else and they
go oh the
the biggest hurricane in the recent
history is coming
national geographic of sending
photographers so you have to shut down
we all just looked at each other there
was not much said to go oh we're gonna
go shoot that hurricane
and literally in about five minutes the
camera's ready to go
there's no question asked you know and
everybody's on the way and i
i walked out to that cliff and then
nobody can hear each other
josh can barely stand but the whole team
is out there and i was watching and
thinking
there's not much for me to do
watching it happen um but for that
that's such a key moment in the film
that we ended up with fur on that cliff
but the reason why we could react to
what all
weather god is because the team is ready
at all times
you know peter i want to ask you
just about the origins of the project
you sort of origin you know you've
you've
found the book uh by jessica bruder and
and
you and francis optioned it together and
it seemed so unusual to
you know to option a non-fiction book to
then make a fiction
film out of it is this the movie that
you and francis thought you were going
to be making when you when you optioned
the book
no not at all it's uh it
is uh i think when we optioned it we
thought that francis would play
linda may and it would be a you know an
adaptation of that book telling linda's
story from
the time that linda you know this her
struggles
ending with her and in the book she
ultimately buys a bit of land
and starts to build her uh um
earthship and uh these uh
and so we you know very traditional idea
of that but at about the same time we
auctioned this book uh then francis
uh was at toronto and uh she slipped out
of some publicity issues want to do
and she went to go see uh the writer
and uh she called me afterwards and she
said i
i you've got to see this movie i think i
found the person who's
who's gonna who should direct our film
and so i got a link i saw it as well
and uh and we knew immediately and then
we got together
on the day of the independent spirit
awards actually in 2017.
uh chloe was there for the writer and i
was there for call me by your name and
francis was there for three billboards
and
we all got together at francis's
apartment
and frank and that was when chloe said
well
perhaps it's linda's story but perhaps
it's something else and she started to
pitch us on the beginnings of her
ideas about this which were really born
of the more you got to know
francis right chloe i mean i mean really
in lots of ways
is fran yeah it's her saying like i want
to be firm like she
she was telling me her alter ego firm we
go okay well that's the main character
in the movie
let's start from there yeah and as soon
as i and as soon as chloe said this is
maybe though how we're gonna make this
movie that's when also francis and i
said okay well we're in a completely new
ballpark for us and that's
uh and that's when dan and molly joined
us uh and came in and and
that's where we all really got kicked
off and began
i know molly you obviously had already
collaborated with chloe on
your two previous films but dan how did
you kind of enter the picture here what
brought you to the project
um i had been a fan of the movies
i i saw songs at sundance like at its
premiere and loved that film and then
obviously loved the writer and and chloe
you and i had kept in touch over there i
called him and said please do this
that's
what happened all right that's uh i was
somewhere in a small town in colorado
dan jeremy any help it was it was
it was a funny conversation like chloe
was like can you do this i was like
yeah let's let's do it and i think my
only question is
are there boats and children
um but i think i think that
i had had a it was kind of an
interesting
i guess the real answer is like i had
worked in a studio context with
non-professional performers
it's probably the real answer i i guess
that's probably why you called me chloe
i've never asked you because you're
really good at with bows and children
but i thought it's perfect
no i mean dan had collaborated with
searchlight you know and
he also um had just i remember
doing songs when i was in the labs i i
used to go to the team of these southern
wild asked them how do you audition
how do you do you know i did go i did
reach out
for help so it feels like a organism
that we all exist in different places
it's just a matter of time
our road cross paths cross
and chloe can you little talk a little
bit more about the adaptation process
like you had the book you had this
concept of
you know this character of of fern how
did you
kind of go from there like how much of
the book is in the movie
a lot um a lot like linda mae swanky bob
wells you know some of the characters
and also all the major locations you
know empire nevada
course at arizona scottsdale nebraska
these are all
the ideas seasonal working amazon
warehouse
firmly you know desert roads rv park
just
the the kind of the world building is so
rich
in jessica's book what my goal was
it was a pretty simple but not easy task
was that
how could we create a character
inspired by a friend that can gel what
jessica already has in her book together
um so that was you know um that was the
goal
i'd seen in another interview where
francis described the character of fern
as being like a docent
that she sort of is like a guide leading
the audience through
this world is that how you do you think
you chloe conceived of the
the character that way too we kind of
have to you know because
because okay well i remember that in our
first meeting uh
friend also said is there because i
think she assumed i want to make a
version with just non-professional
actors having seen the writer
and i felt this specific film because
the writer was very focused on
one person and his own family but this
one i just knew it's a road movie that
we wanted to include as many
interesting stories as possible in the
oral
storytelling tradition of of really the
the you know the american road it's all
part of it people sit down let's just
tell a story as an oral history and i
would really like that
idea and in the film you see people just
start talking
about their lives and in order to make
that into a fictional film in my mind
you need a very very strong listener
and you need someone who has such strong
presence that
the audience aren't going to pick up
their phone they're going to listen
because she
fern she is listening and i don't think
there's many
out there that could be as strong as
francis mcdormand when she look you in
the eyes
uh so yeah and molly what was it like
mixing professional actors i mean
francis mcdormand and david strathearn
with these non-professional actors and
and real-life nomads
well a lot of ways you know like when
working with non-professional actors
there's
you you work at least from my my end of
things in a very
similar way you know there's there's
still contracts you know there's still
all of those things and understanding
what the parameters of what a day
shooting is i mean there's a little bit
of that of explaining maybe what that
what to expect um but um
you know it's always though it was
really fun though to
to be with the non-professional actors
and see them
responding with with francis and with
david
and um i mean at one point i think we
were looking for david and we're like
where is he where'd he go and then we
realized that he was like
he was over with all of the other all of
the other van dwellers at the rtr
and he just like melded in with them
that's great and peter
oh sorry music i wanted to add a little
bit to that
to chloe talking about um fran being a
good listener
i often think that like what makes these
this film what it is is that everybody
is a good listener like from chloe to
josh being being so as he's shooting
like listening to
to where people are are looking and and
and
taking that in as well as all of our
crew too i feel like that's
and then that comes across yeah i think
it's an active listing that isn't and
it's not like a performance in active
listening i mean it literally is
when you get to live with these people
and and we all became a family
certainly the crew but also with the
people we were living with and embedded
with for
four months like it's just this shared
humanity right like like you're
listening to them in the way you
listen or most of us listen to a family
member or somebody
it's it's you because you you want
it's it's the uh it's such an organic
feeling to want to be
present and understand and connected
with them
and uh and that connection i think is is
make is what you feel feel becomes
kinetic and
and what you feel on film because dan
i've seen you say how you kind of had to
cast
the crew in a way you had to be sure
that the people working on the movie
were people who could kind of hang with
working in this manner
i think so yeah i think that's 100 true
i mean like
one of the special things about the
experience was the degree to which the
crew
internalized the core values of how
chloe wanted to make the movie
and it was very clear like actors
are a part of your family sorry not
professional performers have to be
treated like actors
and part of the family and also one
unique aspect about how chloe works
which was new to me
was we did have a traditional kind of
busy production around the shoot
but we we thought about physical space
very specifically to preserve
like an inner circle core experience
that was
as unencumbered by noise and
busy crew as possible and so there was
like this incredible dance
that i frankly had nothing to do with
other than just like watching it
i thought there was an incredible dance
between art camera
grip electric about what they needed to
do to set up
shots to then let the shots happen um
so but but i guess chloe my my
impression of it is like
that basically just happened intuitively
to this
group of people you were dancing on the
outskirt
majority of time is about dodging myself
included
getting out of the shock gosh could just
turn the camera sometimes about you
doing this on purpose
that's how you clear the set just move
the camera but it looks like a little
organism or like an organism like moving
all around like
like the magnets you know that's so like
pushing the other magnets away every
time the camera goes away just scatter
people scatter
but there's a humility to the crew of
like
it's not about like it's it's not about
like if you think about
grip and electric it's like there's kind
of a humility of like
the process is the priority yeah and
supporting the
process like i think was internalized
and i want to be sure to just ask about
fern's van
that i think on like a larger production
you'd assume there'd maybe be multiple
vans i don't know if there was just one
van here and also having it kitted out
in the way that it that it is molly can
you talk a little bit about just
procuring and sort of preparing that van
there was discussion of having more than
one van um
uh well we're finding the van and of
itself
somehow i was finding the van i'm like a
horrible driver i live in new york i'm
like
i don't know we're not letting molly
drop the van no
no but i found it well i found actually
my my a friend of my father's from high
school
lived in lives in la and is like a car
guy and my dad told me this so i called
him up
and he helped us find this van he met
chloe at this
at the at this used uh car place and
found our wonderful
vanguard um but yeah we we
we did make the decision to only have
one van but we had a uh
a trailer that we that we um transported
it to
um two places so that it wasn't having
so much mileage on it
but but chloe can speak to josh really
like
building the whole inside of that van
which is
hopefully some day people can go and
enjoy it for themselves
i'm laughing because um because
there's just one van some days when
someone's driving and i'm driving behind
him thinking
you have to have hands get off the road
what are we going to do
well and with francis driving it it was
yes
a lot of times i'm driving my van uh
then we're just thinking that's it
that's the movie right there are we
gonna go
shoot just some landscapes um but that's
you know again like
a leap of faith right like obviously
there is preparation preparation
preparation but there's at some point
you just gotta
take the plunge and that's what we did
we were not we were ready but we were
also
not ready we can never be completely
ready to make a road movie like this
it's not possible so at some point
well we also said at one point like if
it did if there was a crash like if it
did get hurt
that you would work that in somehow and
yeah i think
i said just keep shooting right you keep
shooting right
uh and i say yes for uh the the
one thing i just want to say that about
that event is that
you know we we had the the the funding
to build it on the stage
um and then really allow the camera to
shoot from different angles
and so josh can do his thing but him
being the dpn
and the the production designer i think
was very important for him
to feel the kind of authenticity that
you will feel
in that van as if you're in there with
fur there can only be two people fit in
there
three tops and when you're in there with
her
you can only be in certain places and if
the camera can go places that you can't
go
um obviously for other type of films
it's great
but for this film that you really you
know we really want you to feel like
that's that small crime space and um
i think it was a lot of discipline on
his behalf to not
have the advantage even though we can
afford it because limitation has
always been our best friend making our
first two films
and we try to remind ourselves that for
this one
and then chloe i want to be sure to ask
you about the fact that you you edit the
film
yourself what is it that you sort of get
from
from doing that yourself and is it
something that you're thinking about
even while you're shooting like do you
know what you can and can't shoot
because you know what you do and don't
need
when you're editing well i've always
added the first pass of my
my films and and i i love editing i
probably
love it more than directly
and i just i just love it and i think
it's because growing up mainly
uh growing up on manga comic books for
me i read more
manga than i did books and and it's like
stories always happens
in frames for me um and so which makes
me sometimes a pretty annoying writer
and director because i'm editing in my
head
so i'm gonna notice that puss put a
little more in the script for people who
doesn't see the edit in your head
or or um sometimes for actors as well
you know like i
i would just need that exact bit i know
i i need
when they're like well i'm ready to give
you a lot more you know who i was able
to sell instead
so it's not always easy but by the same
time it
it comes in handy when you don't have
enough time when you have limited and i
was a you know for
josh knows how i'm going to edit the
film he's going to shoot certain way
and by the end fred knows exactly what i
needed
because she's seeing what i was trying
to do with her at the end of a lot of
improv
that she comes in to do exactly what i
need to make the scene work based on
what we got so
some decisions are made on the spot like
that and then we have time for some
questions we've got in the in the chat
here from the audience
and the so the first question is toward
the beginning of the film there's a
scene where francis has to break
character
and gives her real id to an rv park
clerk
what went into the decision to keep that
scene in the film
it really elevates the stakes and kind
of gives a sense of how realistic the
film truly is
there's also a scene in the film where a
police officer literally calls her
francis
and and reads out her name i like easter
eggs in movies so
i i don't know i think everyone is
is it's all dave's name is dave you know
and and
the the james the guy that plays dave
sung james is dave's son you know
there's just a lot of
it's just being playful you know i think
it's a bit tongue-in-cheek
a bit playful but it's also like the
audience called is did i just see
you know it just being playful really
and then we have another question here
which is can you talk about the
challenges that come with shooting
primarily exteriors i mean does that
create logistical issues as far as
having
cover sets that there's bad weather like
what what does shooting outdoors the way
that you do
how does that impact the production i
just love doing it and i like the people
who have to suffer the consequences talk
about it
i don't think there's an alternative i
mean we don't i don't think we ever had
a discussion about like a cover set
yeah because we also knew that that
chloe and josh could
and would and like to to to use what
what the what the weather is giving us
although i mean there would be
days where we would in the morning the
light wouldn't be the way that you guys
were wanting it for that particular
scene so we might shift and do a
different
different scene so that we so that so
that it was like if it was a hugely
sunny day
and then another question lucky and we
got very lucky weather-wise for the most
part
chloe can you can you talk about the
research that you did into the nomad
lifestyle did you do a lot of traveling
yourself yeah i mean i have traveled
that way quite a bit making my first two
films and then
uh normally again the book is so rich
and the people in the book once they
open up to us that collaboration
uh with with bob wells you know with
linda mae swanky and
suanne carson who is the woman who did
the uh bucket demonstration you know she
really opened up
her community to us and and um
i didn't really spend like years and
years researching no
um it was a very quick process once i
read the book
a few months later we were ready to go
um
i think partially because the nature of
making a road movie
you know and and there is not like one
culture one type of people that hit the
road
it's very different than going to one
place on a reservation in south dakota
you could be you and me tomorrow will
become nomads
once we lo you know once we decide to
let go of this house and then go
so it could be anybody really you know
it's not like a culture you have to get
into understand you have to understand
how to use a bucket
that way you have some street cred
[Laughter]
but peter does the production have to
kind of make some inroads with
the you know some aspect of the nomad
community to you know
find who some of these real people are
to sort of like be involved in some of
these real life events
is that yeah for sure for sure but the
real key to that
in so many ways was also jessica bruder
uh who had written
the book so she had really we really
piggybacked
on a lot of the research she did and the
connections she had made
and and the trust that she had developed
with these people
and so you know uh i think it was the
day after the independent spirit awards
that
chloe was online doing some research and
she typed in
rubber [ __ ] rendezvous uh and she
realized that like that was the last day
it was happening
until another year and so she jumps in
her car
that day if i think i have this right
you drive there
in quartzite arizona it's about a uh
probably a four-hour drive
and you just got there in time that last
day before we would have lost a year
uh to meet bob wells i think you got to
man and jessica had arranged so jessica
knew you were coming
she called or emailed some people and
said you know get some entree for you
and then you you were able to begin
making those connections uh before we
had the ticking clock of another year
when the next uh rendezvous would happen
and then another question the film has
such an incredible
supporting cast swanky's monologue in
the van was particularly moving
how much of that dialogue was improvised
or written and what's the process
like in in getting that performance from
a non-professional actor
i think it's all in the writing really
it's not that different from what it
will any writer would do you know you
interview people and then you listen to
them
and then swanky told me a lot of stories
about her life and
this is this particular story and the
the video she showed me that you end up
seeing in the film
uh almost right away i go that has to
make into the script
and so while i was writing fern's
journey i made sure in a way that can
incorporate swanky in a way that these
things could be part of so
so there's in the script and then on the
day i will give swanky this edited
version of the story she told me once
but it's picked and edited and and then
in that moment she looked at it
she might even she might go off a little
bit improv here and there
um but there's a blueprint which is
quite close to
because sometimes it's translated from
what she has said to me
and she's just repeating the story in
the moment and
obviously by connecting to a friend in
that moment
something else might have come up in her
that i didn't predict
um but it's not like showing up and just
tell me something
about your life because then you'll be
there for days
and then this leads into another
question which is
chloe can you talk a little bit about
your collaboration uh
with josh and the sense of how you kind
of work out blocking do you do you begin
a day with a
shot list like how do the two of you
collaborate in capturing the images
i'm actually really curious to hear what
you guys think because
i actually honestly i don't know what we
do because it's all
it's been too long like all married
couple i have no idea
but i'm sure when you're watching you
can analyze a bit more since you guys
will is literally right next to us and
have to
hear what we need from you know i'll
have to give you things to do
molly do you have any insight on that
yeah yeah i mean my
i always understood that you guys did
have a a shot list and i think that like
over the years i feel like like starting
with songs maybe it might have been not
as
as clear as it was it started to get
with the writer and then with this and
so it is
um and you're trying it seems that
you're tracking like what you know you
need to get visually
um and uh yeah
i i think the analogy of the old married
couple you joke about chloe but it felt
like that
even from you know just like the way
just so symbiotic how you
complete each other's thoughts and
sentences often and knew just
instinctually that he knew you wanted
a certain thing at this moment or you
you know there was a shorthand between
the two of you
that made it very easy for us to
uh you know just get into the rhythm
with you and and support that
we also fought a lot right you know
it's like it's also because because when
you
when you get really comfortable you i
think the
the friction the disagreement um
and it's just constantly wanting just a
little more out of what we can get just
being very greedy and pushing each other
uh some days are good and some days not
so great but then the good days
really is worth it you know um
yeah the crazy thing for me like in
thinking about the question
is after going through the entire cycle
with you guys
is how like divided my head is
about like in some sense you guys have
the openness of like les blanc in his
camera
like and who's to me the great
documentarian
and on the other sense you're also
sitting there as like a party of two
doing the type of shot listing and shot
structuring of like
a scorsese film you know or something
super planned
so i can't make sense of how it's both
things
at once and that to me is the magic it's
like
you would retain the openness to what's
happening in front of you
but you apply like a cinematic rigor of
the edit
and how the shots are are going to cut
together that is
very rooted in narrative cinema and has
nothing to do with documentary
i'm glad you say that because josh is
going to be annoyed if i didn't point
out there was preparation
and i think it's true because i think he
um there's a set of lenses
that we choose from we're very very
strict about that to a point
is almost unnecessary but we we have
faith in that it's done as well as three
films and for me four films now
is that there is only three or four
lenses i use
and i will now change it you know that
means that
josh has to move physically we have to
physically get close to the
the subject and get away and for a film
that can go as fast and and
and unpredictable the the visual
language
has to be really uh consistent
for it to feel that kind of cinematic
that then said it has to be a discipline
to it and i've definitely learned that
like molly said from my first film
just did whatever it wanted and then
slowly realized coming to the edit room
going oh [ __ ] you know this doesn't
feel like it fit and slowly realize
these disciplines are really important
and the disciplines go extend to how
you think about color anything about art
like
they're they're it's it's true narrative
filmmaking in that way
um and i i i'm fascinated by
the two the two worlds of cinema
colliding into something that i think is
distinct to the two of you
and sort of on the same technical lines
there's another question that's about
the sound
in the film is there any difficulties
with location sound recording like this
i mean how
are you using lavs or booms or like how
are you getting because
the sound of the movie it seems really
impeccable especially considering the
locations that you're in
you guys need to talk about wolf because
like
i was going to say when we first started
talking about the movie you're like
there's one human being who can sound
for this
and his name is wolf
he's very passionate about no no loves
he's very very passionate about booming
himself too
um because he feels that that's part of
the whole art of
of the sound and getting into it
oh yeah i mean i made four films and i
have
people that this impulse production and
sound goes
i don't know how you guys did it but
this is the best
dialogue i've ever seen you're just like
in the out there
in that kind of situation how did this
person do it
and then you know and i i it's just you
have to be on the whole time
it's really hard to find a mixer and
opera he does both themselves and
there's not a second he's slacking off
he's constantly listening
and he is always he's in sync with josh
it's like they they
move as as one entity to a point where i
never taught
me to talk to him he just shows up where
he is and i got used to it so much one
time he clearly told
everyone he's going to the bathroom and
i just wrote a whole take until francis
i don't think google is here chloe oh
[ __ ]
you know it's that one time because he
clearly started leaving because it's
that kind of commitment
you get and also performance because i
don't wear
um i don't wear this this stuff what do
you call it like
cans i don't wear them i'm sad not very
rarely so a lot of times i'm now hearing
the performance
how it should be and i highly rely on
always look over a wolf and
he would just he would not and he would
go one more
and then i go ahead you know i trust him
in that way as well
truly like a weirdly spiritual component
to that wolf fellow it's unique
yeah and uh maybe to to conclude chloe i
i just want to ask you
did it seem unusual to you to make this
movie that is you know a fictional
adaptation of a of a non-fiction book
and did it fit well
do you think into your the style that
you've been developing of these sort of
very
realistic naturalistic feeling fiction
films like did it kind of make sense to
you
to make this this adaptation of the of
the book
yes because the first two film
in a way that is is a fictionalized
version
of the non-fiction world and jessica
just have
basically done two three years of my own
research i need to do if i didn't have
her
and her book uh so the process is very
very similar
and is it meaningful to you to sort of
like what is it that draws you to create
these
these sort of very realistic portraits
of the world
well i'm i'm just someone that passed
through
you know like i i don't belong anywhere
and i pass through and there are times i
wanted to stop i wanted to learn and
and i feel so curious about
their way of life and how they see the
world and somehow i know going into it
is going to make myself
a fuller human being and that's that's
what makes me want to make these films
and
and uh i've never been disappointed once
and with that we'll uh wrap up this
conversation i want to thank
all of you for joining us producers
peter spears dan dan
dan janby and molly asher and producer
writer director and editor
chloe zhao thanks everyone thank you
thank you
you